the worst should have been behind us by
now but interest rates are continuing on
their seemingly endless upward March
and for mortgage holders like Ahmet it
means more misery it was about 790
um per month and it's up to 1400 near
1450 now where are you finding the extra
money this is basically the extra hours
we work you know we're on a contract and
obviously we work outside of our
contract through an extra hours
how many hours a week do you work now
well we're on a 39 hour contract and um
we're probably doing double that maybe
more
Ahmet is not alone across the country
lenders are hiking mortgage rates in
response to Growing expectations that
the bank of England will continue to
raise interest rates because inflation
is not coming down fast enough
they've also been pulling products from
the market
a lot of these lenders May well be
temporarily withdrawing their ranges but
we are urging Boris to obviously have a
look at what deal you have right now see
you with your broker if you can
refinance because a lot of lenders are
pulling fixed rate deals the latest data
from the mortgage Market shows that
average two and five-year fixed-rate
mortgages are both now above five
percent their approaching levels last
seen in the Autumn at the time of the
mini budget that means for the average
household looking for a two-year
fixed-rate mortgage repayments have gone
up by more than 340 pounds in the last
18 months
and they could go even higher it's an
unpalatable reality but when you combine
it with soaring food and Broadband bills
as well as rising taxes it very quickly
becomes unbearable
many households are already running down
their savings and are desperately hoping
that things start to improve in the
coming months we should see food price
inflation slowing down to some degree
and if that adds up to signs that
inflation is becoming less sticky that
will mean that the bank of England
doesn't have to raise rates by as much
to slow the economy and bring inflation
under control
and that could mean mortgage rates Peak
at a lower level
households will certainly be hoping this
is the case because many cannot afford
the things to get much worse
Sky News